thanks very much for coming out you guys
especially parents you guys had you did
the heavy lifting in that pandemic
yeah you really did I appreciate you
I appreciate you
you I don't know I'd uh
anybody else without kids did you guys
call your
did you guys call your friends with kids
during the pandemic
oh man just chaos it was chaos
my buddy Ari this guy he was a
stay-at-home dad during the pandemic
he's got a three-year-old and a
five-year-old and I would call him
and just every call was just every call
sounded like
he had called 9-1-1 and dropped the
phone
[Laughter]
ah dude hold on are you bleeding what's
going on what's Happening Sadie no Sadie
Sadie no no no no not now not now no no
no no no no go with your sister then
just go with your sister listen for a
second just go with your sister buddy
Stadium hold on your brother's coming
your brother's coming Sadie wait up go
with your sister and then it's just time
and then it's juice time and then it's
juice time yes thank you and then or I
cancel juice time do I have to cancel
juice time or do I have to cancel juice
time then
yeah I didn't think so I didn't think so
hold on dude I got
bro I got Cheerios I don't even buy
Cheerios there's Cheerios
in every car I got say
wait for your brothers hey man hold up
dude I'm at Whole Foods I gotta call you
back
[Applause]
and I would listen to the whole call I
mean I was
you could drop the phone in his minivan
I'd be in my garage with no
responsibilities just like oh my God
smoking weed like what's gonna happen to
Sade
[Laughter]
tune in next week to see if Sadie gets
her juice
I think I'd be a good dad
[Laughter]
it's almost hurtful
foreign
I know it's not something a good person
has to say
my worst fear is getting a kid stuck in
a ceiling fan
[Laughter]
you ever do that
you're a tall guy you never Jam a kid up
on a ceiling fan
[Applause]
ever once wow what do you got
a nice high lofted ceilings in your
condo that you own
[Laughter]
convenient nobody ever rents their
ceiling fans anymore I'm the only one
I'm the only one with six foot five inch
ceiling fans just perfect
there he is my boy
Lewis not even born yet he's already got
a 16 inch scar above his left eye
I think I'm a good person
get a kid stuck in a ceiling fan it's a
bad time to find out you're not a good
person
I just don't I think I'll adopt
get like a 16 year old yeah
you agree with me it's a good strategy
get get them across the Finish Line real
quick
pick one with a scholarship you know
you laugh because it's a foolproof plan
I just don't ever want to have to get an
infant through an airport
that looks like rock bottom
[Laughter]
you ever see two adults at the airport
just getting lapped
by one little organ grinder monkey off
its leash
grabbing snacks and harassing federal
agents
they're just Tangled Up In charger
cables with no words left getting a
divorce in silence just
[Laughter]
fighting over whose turn it is in
silence
you ever see an actually outnumbered
adult at the airport that's rock bottom
so Mom trying to get three kids through
security she just
quit in her eyes just it's a dead look
in her eyes she was just she was kicking
[__] she was
challenging TSA agent she looked like
she wanted to get arrested she's like
huh
kicking a bear through the swiper ma'am
you can't
huh what who what these yeah they're
mine
this one's got a bomb in her huh
he's got a gun she's got a bomb do we
got to go somewhere to her
to a room with a couch take me to that
yeah I'll go take me to the room with
the couch where I can close my eyes for
the first time in 18 calendar months
I think I'll go to the couch room now
huh
[__] how about the couch room
no I did not pack my own bags two brown
men I didn't recognize did that
couch room now
laughs